we have some revenues staying up late to
give us
the introduction into epidemics on
networks yesterday we saw
how you do this differential equations
but the real world is stochastic it
lives on networks and tom will teach us
how to do this
in a mathematically
foundational way
so
go ahead
thank you very much
before i start thank you very much for
inviting me to this uh
[Music]
semester
and also giving this presentation
although i have been a little bit
worried about if how to do it
and i very much look forward coming here
i will be here five weeks starting
october 2 if i remember correctly
so my background is i come from
probability and statistics and i have
been working in infectious disease
modeling using probability and
statistics for
about 25 years or something like that so
i will be giving two lectures
rather unusually i will give my first
lecture on the ipad doing a bit more of
mathematics
and then in the second lecture i will do
use slides and do more of an overview
presentation and the reason for this is
that the mathematic concerns the the
most basic of all models so for that
reason i thought it makes made sense to
do mathematics for the basic model and
then do more overview of more
complicated models for epidemics and in
particular
with a bit of focus on
epidemics taking place on social
networks which i guess fit quite well
into the theme of this semester
i don't know how many people you are in
there it seems like you're not a huge
crowd but
please interrupt me
i can't to see all of you so please
interrupt me if something is unclear
it's not that i have to say exactly
some specific things so
it's more fun if i am interrupted
i will also try to save these slides and
save them into pdf if someone would like
to look at them later on
okay
i'm ready to start are there some
questions before i start
okay
so what i will be talking about is what
i call the standard
stochastic
s i or epidemic
um
i don't so probably some of you in the
audience know
some of about epidemics but i will
assume that you don't know much about
epidemics but i will assume you know
some basic probability i hope this is a
good assumption so s i r what does that
mean
it means that we assume that individuals
are at first susceptible
if they get infected they go to becoming
infectious
and after some time in the infectious
stage they
go into the recovered state
and it is important to have in mind that
when i say recovered i mean that you are
also immune
so this is the model i will be talking
about
there are other models
for instance
s i s maybe you can guess this means
that you're susceptible
if you get in affected you become
infectious
but then you go back to becoming
susceptible again immediately so there
is no recovered state
s i r s means that you are recovered and
immune for some time but then you go
back to becoming susceptible
this of course depends a little bit on
the time scale you're interested so
i
if we are thinking about covid at least
for the first few strains i think if on
a year perspective i think it would be
all right to model it with an s-i-r
model but if you consider a five-year
period then you should have an s-i-r-s
model
there is also something called s-e-i-r
where e stands for exposed but not yet
infectious
so that is a latent period
and you can make up other models as well
but i will mainly talk about the sior
we're only talking about the sir model
today at least
the standard
what do i mean by the standard what
assumptions am i making
i make the assumption that we have a
fixed and close community
of
size
n
and i will always assume this to be a
large quantity
all the asymptotic all the asymptotics
i'm talking about is when n tends to
infinity
i will also assume that we have no
changing behavior during the epidemic
or prevention
or preventions
this can be built into the model but of
course it makes it more complicated
further i will assume that all
individuals
are
identical i don't know if that's the
correct word but
all have the same sort of distributional
properties
so you can
step aside from that to extend that to
let's say consider different age groups
and maybe some age groups are more
infectious and other less infectious or
whatever but
in the simplest model we have all being
identical
and probably the most restrictive
assumption of all assumptions is that i
will also assume that
all individuals mix uniformly
so of course uh we have left reality i
think christian said that reality is
stochastic so that's why we should do
this but of course this assumption makes
we're not that reality yet
and of course no model is that reality
but clearly you can take some steps
towards reality by the reality by
relaxing these assumptions but
you have to learn how to walk before you
learn how to run
so this is what i will start with and i
think the most restrictive this
assumption is
that individuals mix uniformly
okay so these are some assumptions so
what is the model the model contains
only two
two things
one is that
an individual who gets infected
immediately becomes infectious because
there is no latent period
for a duration
i
i for the infectious period which
follows some distribution and these
infectious period are assumed to be iid
for different individuals
by the way we will sometimes look at two
specific cases
e is the markovian model
that is where i is exponential
gamma
and b is called the read frost model
that is where the infectious period is
known around them and let's assume that
it's one without loss of generality
always in a continuous time setting
i did not hear the comments but always
in a continuous time setting
are we in a continuous time setting yes
sorry for it is you mentioned this yes
this is a continuous time model
so if you say read process i equals one
why don't you just say i is exponential
one
i agree i could do this but uh i think i
will stick to gamma but i agree without
loss of generality you can assume that
it's that gamma equals one as well
a good comment but i will not change it
even though you're correct
the second assumption is that
while infectious
an individual
has
infectious
contacts
at
rate
beta
and each time
what do i call it
with
a
uniformly selected individual
and what do i mean by this
well what i mean by this that
if the contact
if the contacted
is susceptible
it implies it implies he becomes
infectious he or she becomes infectious
and otherwise
nothing no nothing happens
uh beside so these are the
i'm happy to take questions about it but
beside this you have to initiate it
and the the most common initiation is to
assume that
s of north is
n minus 1 i of north is 1
and r of naught
is 0 where
s of t
i of t and r of t
is the number of
susceptible
infectious and recovered
at
t
and please note that s plus
i plus
r equal n the whole time
so it's enough to keep track of two of
these
two of these
[Music]
quantities
okay so this is the model and the
epidemic goes on
until
sometime t
which is
the smallest
t
such that
i of t is equal to zero
and it's easy to
prove that
this is as probability 1 and
and then
one thing then is
r of t
since there are no infectious
individuals at this time point or later
on
that is the same as n minus f of t and
this is called the final size
and one more thing before i take
questions regarding this
model r naught
is the basic
reproduction number
equals beta times
e of i
and the interpretation of this is
the expected number of
infectious contacts
during
the infectious
period
and this will be more or less the number
of
infections
in the beginning
of epidemic
because in the beginning of the epidemic
there are
very few have been infected so nearly
all of these infectious contacts will
happen with other susceptibles i will
come back to this later thing
okay so this was the model i'm happy to
take some questions
if you have any
i have a
comment but
not really a question but
since you say at rate better
that means we have a for salt process
yes yes
it's a poisson process with constant
intensity beta that's correct
which means i could also say that if i'm
infected
i infect each
susceptible uh individual this rate
better over and because of your uniform
distribution yes yes so you can think of
it that you have
you have n or n minus one
independent plus long processes one for
each individual that's an equivalent uh
description of it that's correct
okay
this is the model
what would be interesting things to
study
one is
how
does
epidemic
behave
in the beginning
another one is how does it behave
in the main phase
the third one is
how does the epidemic behave
in the end of the epidemic
uh maybe you're not interested in
time things so how about the final size
z which then is the same thing as r of t
this is a random quantity it's a random
variable so what distribution does it
have
and finally you might be interested in
well i'm sure you can find out other
things to be interested in but i i think
these five things are the most
interesting ones
how
long
will the epidemic last
there's one more thing i'm interested in
which is
i might not be interested in the real
behavior at the beginning i might just
know
what the probability is that you in fact
at least square root of n individuals
yes
yeah that that is that question
i consider that sort of as a sub subset
of uh part a here
because that is part of what happens in
the beginning
so
i think i have
it said that this lecture can go on for
one and a half hour i think it's
suitable to have a short break sometime
in the middle but i have a bit
about an hour
left excluding my break and i will spend
some time on
giving
non-formal proofs of some of these
some of these aspects
but i will actually tell the answer
right now before i prove things
the epidemic in the beginning
behaves more or less
like a branching process
i
and later
i will tell you why this is the case and
i will also tell you what branching
process it behaves like
the main face
will behave like
and here i'm only considering the
markovian model
it behaves like
a deterministic
process
with
gaussian
or there is a gaussian process around
this deterministic but i would say
gaussian deviations
but this is a week of week convergence
type of results so it's for the whole
process not for a specific time point
the end of the epidemic
also behaves like a branching process
but
an unusual
analysis of a branching process because
it is when you start with many
individuals
starting
with many individuals
and having negative drift
so it is how
so you start the branching process with
thousand individuals and it has negative
drift that is how the epidemic will
behave like
the final size
will converge to two point distribution
we are tall
solves
this equation
and
and the the
the how long
by the way
what comes here is only for the
only for a supercritical situation
because
if it's if the branching process is
subcritical it will never grow so then
there will be no main phase and there
will be no
end after the main phase
how long will the epidemic lost well the
answer is that
either this part i don't know as well as
the other parts but sort of like this
some constant times login
plus another constant
plus another constant times log n
of course you can combine the
the two constants with log n but it's
nice to think of it like this because
it's the this is the beginning
this is the main phase
and this is the end
i have a question
yes when z over n goes to zero or tau
do you know
for d
yes
which probability the two events have
that's a very good question
um
the probability
let's put it like this p of
z divided by n converges to two
depends
on
this random quantity f
so that's a good question
it is maximized
if i is non-random so this probability
is maximized
in the read frost model
and in that case so the
read in the read frost model
it is maximized and then
it converges
to size to with probability to
but if i is random
[Music]
there is a smaller probability and you
this makes sense so
suppose it's extremely random
it has mean one let's assume and suppose
that the infectious period is zero with
a large probability and then very big
with a small probability then of course
with a with a large probability it will
go extinct immediately
so the more random i is in some sense
the infectious period is in some sense
the less likeliest to have a big
outbreak
what if
i is exponentially distributed
in that case
if i remember correctly
it is
does this make sense it is this one over
on water one minus
one over r naught and it
yeah this is correct
so if it in the markovian case it's um
one minus one over or not
and this comes if you have
if your branching process has
is a markovian so
it is
you live exponential lives and you give
birth at exponential rates then
this is the
probability of going to infinity
many good questions i i think i remember
these things correct but
i wouldn't bet my life on it but i think
this is what it is like
okay
my
goal
is
to
sketch
of
a
followed by
d
followed by b
e i don't have
capacity
of doing i wouldn't be able to do that
c i think it's slightly less interesting
however i might not
be able to
do all three of these so if someone has
some other preference i could change
this order
but i think it makes sense to start with
the beginning of the epidemic because if
you don't understand the beginning
then maybe you're not so interested in
what comes later
so i think to some extent it might be
nice if you don't get to everything to
do b
because there will be another talk here
on what's called the probabilistic
methods
and which will be sort of related to
your proof of b so i think it would be
nice to see those
did i understand correctly i should i
not do b
no i'm saying if you can't do everything
you want to do just to a and b
okay
okay i will do uh
so
do i understand correctly that you
suggest this yes
okay
i will do that
that's actually the order i had started
off planning for but then
i thought that would change my mind but
i'm happy to do it like that
okay
so let's
start with then the initial phase
and then i claim that the epidemic
is close to a branching process
let's see what sort of intuitively why
and the reason is that
more or less all
infectious contacts results in infection
what is the beginning maybe you want to
say
you can say that it's up to square root
of n people have been affected or a
fraction epsilon times n
i i will not sort of go into that rigor
of proofs but anyway a small fraction
and if a small if no more than a small
fraction has been affected when you
choose this uniformly individuals it's
very unlikely that you will pick someone
who already has been infected
um
so this means that each infected person
he or she recovers independently of
everything else that's always true
but now in the initial phase
each infectious person also infects
independent of the others
so this is sort of the the branching
process regime
so that's sort of the intui
the intuition behind it
but now i will prove this using a
coupling i will couple
the branching process
and the epidemic
i will actually do it
for all m
and to my help to do this i have the
following three sets of random
quantities
first
i assume that we have a set of iid
poisson processes
with
rate
beta of course i could chose them to
have rate one but i chose
i decided to go have them rate beta and
i will call them x
one x 2
and so on
and then i also have i i the infectious
periods
i call these ones
i
and these follow the distribution that
we want for the infectious period
and then i will also have i iid uniform
zero one variables
so if you give me these
random quantities i will use them
to construct the branching process
as well as
the epidemic for any given value of n
so
construction of the branching process
the first individual
infects
according
to
the
the first
[Music]
poisson process but you do this only up
until
i one
so one
up until t equals i1 after that you stop
and then
sorry in fact by this i mean give birth
so i mean i'm thinking of the epidemic
but if i want to put the terminology
from branching process theory infects
corresponds to giving birth
and when when this thing happens
the individual recovers
which is the same thing as dies in the
branching process
and your branching process is continuous
time
yes sorry made by sure
this so both the epidemic and the
branching process runs in continuous
time
and
as new people get infected
they
start
infecting
according
to
well the next one that gets infected
picks up the second poisson process
and you start it at the time when you
get infected you start it
and then you run it forward in time
until
i mean
i haven't written what time this happens
but when it happens when the individual
are born or infected
you start running the what's on process
for giving new births and you do this
until sometime later time
point
when that
infectious period or life length is over
and
so on
this
this produces
a branching process
with
[Music]
constant
birth
rate
beta
and life length
i
is that
clear to people
i mean this is this is not very deep
i think you might want so i think we
have seen burst process where just we
don't have time in them
so maybe for the non-experts you could
just show a picture and say what the
first person if they don't have just
wait but also like
oh
i didn't exactly here but the poisson
process
so maybe you get infected suppose
someone gets infected here
then you start running this poisson
process
and the poisson process after
exponential time periods
and then
this is your life length
i2 if it's the second individual
and here you have a birth
and then
so the poisson process have exponential
time points between births
and then is another duration maybe the
next birth comes here and then maybe
another birth comes here
and also another one here but this one
you don't care about because you you die
here so you just
you
you don't take into account what happens
after your death
so
this you you forget about
and then
here
some
sorry
here someone was born so then that
individual starts
a new a new
process and we can write this here and
maybe
um maybe the life length of that
individual is maybe shorter maybe it
only has one birth
before it dies
but so what happens next well the next
thing in time is that this individual
was born so then you do a new thing
um
maybe i don't know this figure was all
that good but uh
it's nice
okay
so this was how you produce the
branching process and
note that
you won
you two
were not used
but now we produce the and now we
construct the epidemic
[Music]
for
size
n
and
the first thing you would do
is to label individuals
they are interchangeable so you can
label them in any way you want but label
them one up to n
and let's say that the index case
has
label one if you prefer you can give it
label seven it doesn't matter
and then
we the index case
has
infectious contacts
according
to
x one
to the poisson process the first poisson
process
up
until
t equals i
one
so
the pos you use the first
person process and the first infectious
period to the index case
you use the second poisson process and
the second infectious period
not to individual with label 2
but to the second person getting
infected
but we haven't said who does this person
infect
so the first infection let's see now
whatever
yeah
each
new infection
is
with
individual
you want to pick a uniformly distributed
individual
among individuals one up to n and for
that to use the uniform numbers
so the first time you have an infection
you use u1
and you must multiply by n
and then you don't truncate but you
round it upwards
so this thing
quantity will be
either one
up to n
so the first infection
that happens well there could be no
infection of course if this poisson
process has no birth
or no event before
so if this poisson process does not have
a jump before this then nothing more
nothing else happens but suppose there
is a jump
at some time point before
it dies
then you use the first uniform number to
to select which individual gets infected
so maybe the next individual happens to
be individual seven
wait i have a question so it could be
that this happens to be one which was
the one don't you want class one maybe
otherwise i infect myself possibly
yes
[Music]
yeah uh
it's easiest
it's easiest if you allow if you allow
to infect yourself this
this can be adjusted by
taking beat the prime equal uh
n minus one divided by n to beat or
something but it makes it easier if you
allow to also infecting yourself of
course this doesn't make sense but uh
from a
asymptotic point of view it doesn't
matter but that's a good point that it
doesn't make sense to
infect yourself
it should look like this or possibly
the inverse of this i don't know
um
so
if uh whoever maybe this was individual
seven
and then individual seven
uh gets to use
x2
and i2
and then the next time you do and you
too
no sorry u2 is maybe the
the u's are used in order of infection
maybe i mean it could very well be that
this first individual has
three as a as was the case here so here
you use u1 to decide who gets infected
here you use u2 to decide who gets
infected
here you use u3 to decide so the use you
take in the order as say the infections
occur
and then whenever a new person is
infected you take the next poisson
process available
and the next
infectious period you could take any
other poisson process as well because
they're iid so it doesn't really matter
and i have another question so if i'm
now in
individual 15 with infecting
yes in fact one of the people before me
if individual 15 got infected what did
you say after that
so you have the u15 times n
and that could happen to be two
so you would in fact backwards and
you'll find yourself
uh
you could infect individual two but the
problem is
sooner or later probably
one of these selected individuals
will already have been infected
all right that's my question
yes
so that's that's what i'm coming to now
uh
so that should have written here
if
this
individual
individual
has not been infected
before
then you have an infection
otherwise
you do nothing
and you call this a ghost
event
so a ghost event is when
a selected person for infection
has already been infected
that is called the ghost event
this construction
but okay but
uh you can continue this
and
when you have a ghost event you do
nothing
but maybe there's a new infection and
then someone else who has not been
affected gets infected so you do this
and eventually this stops
so
this
produces
the
standard sior epidemic
and let's say
and so on
yes
that's also a ghost event
maybe i could have avoided infecting
yourself but
that's more complicated how would you do
with individual seven to avoid picking
that particular so
um but yeah let's call that also ghost
event
because you have been infected earlier
so this this will produce the epidemic
but one an observation
is that the branching process
and the epidemic
are
identical
up until the first ghost
because
unless you see a ghost each time in the
epidemic a new person gets infected
and the same happens with
the branching process
so
what is the probability
that we have no
ghost event
among
the first
okay infections
uh
i realized that i'm i'm
missing this fact that was pointed out i
think by christian that i'm
avoi
i'm neglecting this fact that you can
infect yourself
so but forgive me for that
so think of that you exclude that
possibility the first infection
will never be a ghost event unless
if we don't allow for the for uh
infecting yourself so there will be no
ghost event in the first time the next
time
when one person has been infected
no sorry this uh
this applies also if you can infect
yourself this is the index case the
index case will never be ghosted the
next time what's the probability that
there is a ghost event well only one
person has been infected so the
probability
not to select that individual is one
minus one over n
and the next infection then two people
have been infected
so the probability that your uniform
number does not pick one of these two is
one minus two over m
and this goes on up until one minus i
think it should be k minus one over n
maybe it should be k over n that i don't
know
and this is
more or less
e to the power 0 times e to the power 1
minus n times e to the power 2 minus n
[Music]
times e to the minus k minus 1 over n
and there we see that we have in the
exponent here you bring out 1 over n you
see that you have the sum 1 plus 2 plus
3 up to k minus 1 over n so this is
e to the minus
1 over n
k
times
k minus 1
over 2.
so then this will converge to 1
if
k
is
small o of square root of n
so this means that
[Music]
the epidemic
and the branching process
sorry they are exactly identical
up
until
i write
square root of n if you're
maybe you want to raise it n to the 0.49
or something if you prefer
or maybe you should have epsilon times
square root of
in particular
we can then say that
the epidemic
is subcritical
if
r naught which was beta times the
expected value of i
was smaller than one
critical if it is equal to one and
supercritical
if it is bigger than one
and uh from the branching process
we can
compute i mean not
depending on these infectious paired
eyes it might not be simple
uh
probability that final size
equals k
and the probability to have a minor
outbreak
which is the sum over k
yes
so
with this i think i am done with the
first part
so i have tried to explain
or sort of mathematically show
that up until you have seen
close square root of n infections
the
epidemic can be coupled
to a branching process so for that
reason
we
we
and the coupling happens with with a
probability turning to one so for that
reason we can use result from branching
processes
are there questions
there was an anonymous
basic question
sorry
can you hear me from back here
yes
okay uh so
yeah i'm familiar with this construction
i've always been curious so the uniform
um random numbers uh help you
decide which contacts to make so that
you can map onto the sir but from the
perspective of the branching process
they don't come in at all right
yes
okay the reason the reason for that is
that in the epidemic this is true also
in reality in the epidemic if you get
infected later on in an epidemic
then several of your infectious contacts
will be with people that have already
been infected infected so over the
course of the epidemic
infected people will infect fewer and
fewer over the course
and that is not allowed in a branching
process in a branching process
you give birth to equally many
individuals whether you are born in the
beginning or later on in the branching
process so that is
so later on in the epidemic it is not
the branching process
[Music]
did i answer your question or did i just
interrupt you
are there more questions
uh
there was something in the question and
answer that was fairly long i
general thought just wondering whether
these compartmental models are still the
current state of where we are in the
epidemiological modeling and that's a
good question so
uh
so let me address that question
so the s i r model
assumes that
my infectivity or my rate of infectious
contacts here i get infected
so this is time
so this is an answer to the question
time of
infection
this model that i talked about says that
i have
a constant
infectious rate
that lost for a random time
so this here is my infectious period
it lasts for a random time and the level
is beta
for different individuals
the model i'm talking about
everyone has the same beta but people
have different durations
i don't think this is a the best
description of how my infectivity
evolves over time
so a better
or
more realistic
if i put another one here so another if
i have two individuals i don't know if i
had colors here yeah i do
so another
whoops this looks strange but another
one
would have a the same beta but
but the shorter period
more realistic would be
something like this
in the beginning i have a small
infectivity then it grows up
and then i start shedding a lot of
viruses but then i start staying in bed
so i meet fewer people but i still shed
so maybe it looks like that and another
individual might have
less infectious things but also
happening quicker in time and another
one could have a very long thing like
that so a better description would be
that you have a
sort of a
some type of general stochastic process
but a nice observation
is that
for the final size
only
the
random
the
distribution
this
three
fusion
of
the
integral
so if you
your infectivity
process so all that matters for the
final size is
uh
is sort of
this area so this area was like this for
another
person it was
like this
so this is a random thing this area
and all that matters for the final size
is not when it happens in time but the
distribution of this area so you can
actually be as flexible
by choosing a suitable
uh duration here so for that matter if
you
this is this model is very restrictive
but if you're only interested in the
final size then this model
captures equally much as this model
would
i don't know if you're happy with that
answer but that's the answer i can give
other other questions
it seems like not
i would be happy to have a three minute
break now is that okay with others
sure
okay so i will come back in three
minutes but i will be uh
here on all the time
okay so let me talk about uh
the main phase of the epidemic now
[Music]
and
this is
maybe a little bit more technical so i
will avoid some things anyway but
what is this connected to this is
connected to something called density
depends
jump
markov processes
mark of
processes
and some people call it kurt's
theory
tom kurtz is the founder of this area
and
this only considers the markovian
version i don't think it's very
different if you do some other but i'm
thinking of the the markovian version
now where the infectious period is
exponential
and i will also
simplify life by saying that initiation
i would assume
[Music]
that we have a small positive fraction
of infectives
for some small value so we start not
with one person because in the beginning
you cannot approximate
what we will do is
we will
we will look at these and we will divide
these processes so
s of t
divided by n and i of t
divided by n
will behave much like
sorry
it will behave much like a deterministic
process
y of t
and
if we started in the beginning that
would not be true because in the
beginning on the proportion scale
the the fraction of infectives is zero
so we will never re leave the state zero
if we started like that
okay
let me define z
n
of t as this s of t
i of t
i write n because i want to sort of
show the dependence on m so this is the
bivariate process and recall that
the sum of s plus i plus r equals n so
it's enough to keep track of two of
these coordinates
and further later i will use s bar of n
to denote
when i divide by n so this is the
fraction process
and suppose at some time t
suppose that
z n of t
equals
s and i
and then there are two possible events
for our epidemic
because we are living in continuous
times there will never be two events
happening on the same exact time points
so there are two possible events one is
an infection
uh
which means that the state we go from
state s to
s i to s minus one
i plus one
and what is the rate for this
what is the rate at which we have an
infection
well you should think of this suppose i
am infectious
then the rate at which i infect you
the rate at which i have infectious
contact is beta
but the probability that my contact is
with the susceptible is s over n
so this is for me
if i'm infectious but now there are more
infectious people around so this is for
all infectious people so this is the
rate at which we see infections
and
the other event is of course a recovery
and in that
situation we go to
s is unchanged and i minus ray i and
this happens at rate i times gamma
because
each individual whose infectious
recovers at rate gamma so the overall
rate is i times gamma
so
we now
construct
uh
maybe
increase this
it's more better go wheel to write it
like this
s times i plus
minus 1 1
s i
plus 0 minus 1.
that's the same thing as what i wrote
but i write it like that because i will
these things will appear later
we now construct the epidemic
using
two
independent
now for some reason i chose rate one
for a song processors
and i call them
i give them we have two of them so i
give them a label
and one
and the other one
so the first one
will
count
infections and the second one counts
recoveries
and
to my use
i will introduce
two functions
set
beta
minus 1 1
x y equals
beta times x times y
this will be the infection rate
and beta with label 0 1.
x
y
is gamma times y and this will be the
recovery rate
then
this thing here
an equivalent
way of saying this is the following
i divide by some small h and ask for the
probability
that z then of t
plus h so a small step forward in time
[Music]
that we have reached
stage
s
i
but with an infectious jump
given that we at time t
or in state s i
what is the probability for that
well the probability for that
is
we have it already up here
so it is i times beta but i will write
it slightly different it is
beta times
i times s over n
plus
smaller terms which i will forget from
now on
and i will write this slightly different
i will write it as n times
beta times i over n times s over n
and then this is the same thing as n
times this function
evaluated
which in turn is the same thing as beat
up minus one one
okay
similarly for the other jump
it will be the same thing but for the
other argument maybe i should have a t
here as well
i skipped these intermediate steps but
that's not the problem
so this
that's the correct question wouldn't it
be better to write
probably
n of t plus h is equal to z n of t plus
this change
so then you see the difference already
yeah that's a good suggestion although i
don't want to change it now but probably
that would have been better i agree with
that
okay
and of course these probabilities uh
please note that they are scaled by one
of so both probabilities are very small
and the remaining probability is of
course that nothing happens and that's
much more likely in a small time
increment the most likely thing is that
nothing happens
but i will skip that
okay
uh
so this
it was
equivalent more or less to this
and this in terms this looks at the
small time increment but you can write
this in terms of a differential
sorry an integral equation as well
so this will be the same thing as saying
the following
that my process z
n of t
is equal to the starting point
plus
the number of infectious
so this quantity here is what is the
effect
on this bivariate process when you have
an infection
and then we see how many infections have
there been
and for that we use this poisson process
rate one
but we can we don't observe it at time t
but we observe it at these rates that we
integrate from time zero up to t
so it is
n times this integral from zero t
beta
minus 1 1
of z bar n of s
d s
plus
0 minus 1 times the number of
recoveries that we have seen
this is this is actually saying more or
less the same thing because if you look
at this
integral equation and you take a small
increment future in time
it really says exactly what the the
lines above say i think there was a
comment there
so everything is random here right so
these are stochastic
these are stochastic integrals yes
so in a sense we observe the poisson
process
after some stochastic time point and
depending on what rate we currently have
we take this rate uh over time
so when when the rate is high we make a
big leaps in the poisson process because
so this is the same thing
and this is the
theory for counting processes of course
this is a little bit complicated i took
i read a course on counting processes a
long time ago so i'm a bit familiar with
that but if you're not familiar with
this of course this is
not
completely trivial i agree with that
okay
now let me introduce
uh the centered
process the centered
awesome processes
and i call them y hat
and by this i mean for any process the
center point so y hat
of
t
is
y of t
minus t the minus t that's the mean
of a poisson process
if i use that notation
it follows that
now i look at the
mean process
that will equal to
the mean the this is just dividing by n
so then i must divide also the jumps by
one over n
and then i observe these
centered process in the same time point
i don't write that so
it's the same argument so this should go
here
and divide by n you don't need because
we have this factor n already in front
of the integral and z and bar you have
divided by n so n one over n no but n is
inside
uh it's inside i'm sorry um
[Music]
see now
yes and then plus
but what you're aiming for is still we
will see when you look at the mean that
the the n divided by n will cancel out
with the mean thing but it when it's the
process you cannot do that
uh let's see if i have done it correctly
here and then it's one over n of this
other process
but remember now that this center
process then we have subtracted the mean
so then we must add the mean as well
uh
and i call that
a little bit complicated t
f
of z
n of s
d s
have i said what f is
this thing here is
minus 1 1
beta minus 1
1
z
and of s
plus
0 minus one
beta zero minus one
zero
of s
and here because
so this is just um
this is just
the
because we
we subtracted the mean here then we must
add the mean here so here we're adding
the mean and here this one divided by n
and the n in frontier would cancel out
because
when we look at the mean
we can cancel these things out but not
in the poisson process itself
so that was a good question
that you had earlier
okay
now
i i mean
i think
my time is running out probably yeah so
i just have a couple of minutes left but
so i will not finish
what i intended to but i knew i wouldn't
anyway this
what is this thing here
we are observing a centered poisson
process
at some time
yes
so this here
this is a water n and this here is some
constant more or less
so we are observing a center process
with something m times some constant it
has mean zero since it's a centered
process and the poisson process
observed at time n times a constant
let's say exactly n
has variance n
but if we divide something which has
variance n
we divide it by one over n
we get the one n squared
so these two things
sorry
both this and that will converge to zero
in yeah in probability over uniformly
over finite time due horizons
so i'm skipping a lot of details here
also in probability
on time on it
so
uh the
i'm not claiming this is a full proof
but this is anyway an indication that
z
n of t
converges
in probability
to z of t
which is defined by
this is a deterministic thing
it's defined by
z of t is equal to z of naught plus
the integral z f of z of s
d s
and if you think about it
uh
[Music]
if you instead write this integral
equation in terms of a differential
equation
then
this differential equation
having
s of t and i of t
as fractions
what we have there is
equivalent to the model s prime of t is
equal to
beta
s of t i of t
and i prime of t is
minus beta s of t
i
of t
sorry minus plus
and minus gamma i of t
and this here is called the
deterministic
s
or epidemic
and
i have no chance to say this gaussian
thing but
this
if you look at
one
over
sorry if you look at square root of n
of y and of a poisson process observed
n times t
minus t this process will converge to a
brownian motion
and you you can use that
to show that
also
square root of n
z n of t
minus this deterministic process
will converge to
some other
gaussian
process but i
i understood i would not have time for
that to do that
question so when you
if you go back so this is very nice so
we understand intuitively
that essentially what you use at the
center for solves
have sort of variance which is square
root of t and that is sort of valence is
t and then
and therefore they become sort of if you
divide by t equals to zero
what
what details did you hide from us if we
wanted to make that a real proof
uh well one important
factor is that
we are integrating over time so the the
the deviation could grow over time
but then uh
we have this
so
what we should what we are should which
i did not there is something called the
ground i don't know how to pronounce it
growing well in a
inequality
this
assures
that
deviations
don't uh
i don't know what to call it explode or
something like that
that's the main thing which i skipped
and for the
for this other part
you need to know a bit about
convergence weak convergence and i don't
have all of it in my head but you do get
the differential so he this involves a
differential of this f
of z
of s
if i if i would just want the law of
large numbers not the gaussian process
so your proof doesn't need to inequality
or something like that all you need is
order right classes center pressures
yeah
if i
yes that's my um
i wouldn't bet all my uh uh belongings
on this but i uh i think this is the
case
because when you go to some more channel
settings even in your papers you
eventually
sort of are relying on groups inequality
to bound sort of terms like this right
yes in more complicated situations i
will not talk about them because they
are too complicated to describe in a
scientific talk and i don't know if i
have all the details
on top of my head either but
they're for a more complicated situation
in particular we have an epidemic taking
place on
dynamic networks so then things are a
bit harder and then i think we need more
as you say
i can have a brief look at my paper but
but i wouldn't be able to
to present details about that no no but
i just want to understand how much you
cheated here so you didn't cheat much so
except no here there was not much
cheating at all
except for the corner inequality
once you do that
hey yes you very much
more questions well let's first think
other questions
okay top we look forward to your next
lecture
okay so i will meet you on friday it's
my
evening so it's probably your morning
yes
okay thank you very much and see you
next see you on friday
thank you